when we were dreaming about having a  family didn't look like this did it  lost jobs teens with severe anxiety  parents conducive  [Music]  why'd you move the family here still  looking for the simple life  [Music]  as those days are gone clark long gone  you got the weight of the world on your  shoulders i really wish i could get  drunk sometimes  you're saying you're super bad  well we've seen superman before we've  seen him  am i a bad father we're gonna be all  right  no one ever dreams about the problems  but every life has them  even the extraordinary ones  [Music]  superman and lois two-hour premiere  event tuesday february 23rd stream free  next day only on the cw app